man i'm
i'm hyper bullish on bitcoin like in as
a long-term asset
i think um
i think bitcoin is going to do for money
what the internet has done for
information
what social media has done for
communication
um
in the short term
i i look at bitcoin as a longer term
in investment i don't look it is just
i'm not a trader i'm not there like
every single day trying to time the
markets and catch the dips and you know
sell the tops etc
um
but i think
every day it becomes more obvious to me
why it's such a good idea yeah right the
more that governments debase their
currencies the more that they do this
all the nonsense restrictions and
infringements on rights and liberties
that they've been doing the more um you
know every time they pass these
multi-trillion
dollar bills every time that and this is
on a global level as well right like not
just the us if you see what's going on
around the world i mean some currencies
i was in
i was in turkey before coming to the u.s
like i mean the turkish leader i got got
battered and
if you imagine
one thing i find interesting with
bitcoin is the way that it's viewed
as such a high risk investment or such a
high risk play
and
most people don't understand how risky
it is to just like have all your money
in cash right some people think the
safest thing you can do is just have all
your money in cash and put it in the
bank don't buy stocks don't buy land
don't buy gold don't buy bitcoin just
keep your money and i'm like that is
guaranteed
to drop guaranteed a decade from now
100 guarantee if you keep
your hundred thousand dollars in a bank
a million dollars in debate it's gonna
lose a lot
of its value
um
now on a on a day-to-day level a
month-to-month level you know bitcoin
goes up and down he was like well twenty
thousand sixty thousand forty thousand
like but if you look at it over a period
of years i know it's still relatively
young compared to most asset classes but
i think it's to me it's virtually
borrowing some ins it's i don't know
what could happen but i think it's
virtually guaranteed a decade from now
like bitcoin is going to be worth like
five years from now is going to be worth
considerably more